[Musique]
la peur va changer de camp les paroles
tenues hier soit à huis clos par le
président de la république le conseil de
défense s'achève à l'elysée les
principaux ministres quittent le palais
en ayant pris plusieurs décisions en
réaction à l'attentât contre le
professeur de conflans sainte honorine
on nous a annoncé de nouvelles lois on
nous annonce maintenant un nouveau plan
je crois que nous ne pouvons plus de cet
empilement de stratégie qui se
juxtaposent les unes aux autres sans que
jamais rien ne soit mis en oeuvre
concrètement les opérations de police
ont lieu et auront lieu dans les heures
dans les jours qui viennent je peux pas
en dire beaucoup plus mais elles sont
très nombreuses à être constant des
dizaines d'individus à un lien forcément
avec l' enquête mais dont nous avons
manifestement envie de passer un message
ces opérations police elles ont comme
but premier
faire que la sidération change de camp
les français ont été sidérés à la
décapitation par cet attentat islamiste
et nous devons aux français que la peur
la sidération change de camp à lyon en
marge de l'hommage au professeur sam
elle pâtit ces images de nos confrères
de lyon mag des individus en scooter qui
viennent narguer les policiers qui
sécurisaient le rassemblement rôdé aux
roues arrière message
et insultes président de la république
se trouve aujourd'hui réduits devant un
acte de guerre perpétrés contre un
citoyen français
un très convenue et déjà très tardif ils
ne passeront pas qui osera faire des
cours d'instruction civique en
présentant des caricatures
pour sigean se dire illustrer la liberté
d'expression on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
cette guerre contre l'islamisme
on l'amène pas et j'accuse le chef de
l'état de ne pas suffisamment la mener
j'entends de ce d'arman avec ce
passionné est typique et qui va expulser
231 231 radicaliser étrangers et j'ai
envie de lui poser une question est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les radicaliser
france est donc plutôt que de dire qu'il
va faire 2 qui va renvoyer deux cent
trente et une personnes
voilà longtemps que le gouvernement
aurait dû s'atteler à cette tâche et
renvoyer immédiatement dès qu'ils le
peuvent
les fichiers s est rangé pour
radicalisation dehors toute personne qui
disait il ya un problème dans notre pays
étaient poursuivis accusés et ce faisant
d'ailleurs qui pour n'a laissé tomber un
qui pensez-vous responsables politiques
qui pensent et vous écouter ceux qui
manifestaient dans la marche contre
l'islamophobie se reconnaîtront qu'ils
fassent leur examen de conscience mais
on n'est pas dans la politique tellement
la situation est grave dans le pays
on voit sur la question de la laïcité
toute une série d'acteurs tenir des
discours ambigu je parle bien entendu
d'un certain nombre de députés a
souligné mais pas seulement
et ceux qui se comportent ainsi ne se
comporte pas de façon républicaine sont
grandement responsables du climat qui
existe dans ce pays
pourvu lockers et doris tu verras si
lille
ici que le fonds puisse dr otto qui a
décapité s'appelle le mise à part c'est
à toi met en scène sa toile entre ce
professeur dans les jours qui ont
précédé la mort de samuel pâtit sur les
réseaux sociaux
les messages des vidéos appelant à sa
suspension
dévoilant son nom ou son adresse une
cavale numérique émanant souvent de
comptes anonymes qui pourrait avoir
influencé son assassin
j'ai reçu après avoir fait les missions
de ces news en duplex depuis ma
permanence des must des messages
d'insultés de menaces j'ai même reçu un
message que j'ai signalé au procureur et
au préfet de mon département un message
d'une personne qui se réjouit de
l'assassinât du professeur
alors elle doit rester une terre
d'accueil la france doit rester une
terre de liberté
et aujourd'hui elle ne peut plus être
une terre d'accueil parce qu'il lui faut
déjà assimilé et donc j'ai demandé au
préfet de seine-saint-denis de faire
fermer la mosquée de pantin puisque son
dirigeant a relayé le message qui
consistait effectivement à dire que ce
professeur devait être intimidé en
relayant d'ailleurs l'adresse du collège